ونتابع مشاهدينا اذا هذه الصور المباشره
من مدينه
عمليات الانقاذ تحت انقاذ المبنى السكني
في مدينه ديليبرو الذي تعرض لقصف روسي كما
ذكرناها وبحسب وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
فقط بلغت حصيله القتل 17 قتيلا و 73جريحا
حاكم المنطقه ايضا مشاهدينا قال ان عدد
قتلى هذا الهجوم الصاروخي الذي دمر مبنا
زكريا ارتفع الى 14 قتيلا هناك طبعا تناقض
في اعداد القتلى حتى هذه اللحظه فرق
الانقاذته واصل عملها الليل هناك بعض
السكان ايضا في منطقه انضم اليهم في حسب
بعض الانباء همم البحث عن عجين همم ايضا
حاكم المنطقه المشاهدين قال انه حتى الان
تم اقاده ثمانيه وثلاثين شخصا بينما فقد
اربعه 24 اخرون حتى الان عدد سكان الموصل
تحت الانقاض معروفا وهذا الهجوم مشاهدينا
هجوم روسي وقع ظهر امس السبت وتسبب ايضا
في اصابه 64 شخصا على الاقل
وزن معكم اذا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الصور المشاه المباشره لعمليات انقاذ
الناجين تحت الانقاض هذا المبلغ السكني
الذي تعرض لقصف روسي يوم امس